m'lee chronicles the life of Robert
hunter an advocate for the working class
and poor in the 19th and 20th centuries
he discusses mr. hunters book poverty
and his proposed solutions many of which
were adopted by states and localities
this event from Arizona State
University's downtown Phoenix campus is
40 minutes good morning I'm really
pleased to be here to talk about the
subject of my latest book who is a man
called Robert hunter who was very active
in the progressive movement at the
beginning of the last century and
actually pioneered a number of very
important social reforms of that era
including the first child welfare a
child labor laws prohibiting employment
of children in factories mines and and
and sweatshops
when in 1903 Robert hunter a social
worker from Indiana married Caroline
Phelps Stokes daughter one of the
richest men in America the national
press took notice the Phelps Stokes
family they also had a dodge connection
so they were the Phelps dodge Stokes
family had amassed several fortunes in
banking real estate railroads and mining
during the last half of the 19th century
and what came to be known as the Gilded
Age in America when it was revealed that
the young couple would forsake the
luxuries of their country mansion to
live in a slum neighborhood in New York
City to in order to continue their work
among the poor that had brought them
together it was front-page news the
decision of the hunters to join the
Socialist Party of America shortly
thereafter caused an even greater
sensation
while much of the press coverage of the
young couple was accurate
the humble origins describe to hunter
were not really a true hunter rather
than being the portal lad from rural
Indiana that they reported almost
inferring that he was this rural hick he
actually came from a relatively
prosperous family and and one with a
reasonably respectable pedigree the fact
that he had chosen a career in social
work was a consequence of strong
altruistic impulses based on Christian
beliefs that he first sought to act upon
close to home in Indiana and later in an
ever-widening
marina Hunter was born in 1874 in Terre
Haute his family owned the company that
manufactured horse-drawn carriages his
father served in the Civil War rising to
the rank of colonel and you Melissa says
grants 21st Illinois regiment after the
war he settled in Terre Haute and became
active in local and state politics most
notably he served out on the local
welcoming committee for Grover Cleveland
when his campaign for the presidency
brought him to Indiana in 1884 10
year-old Robert Hunter wrote a white
pony at the head of the welcoming parade
and was introduced to the presidential
candidate who in the time-honored
tradition of political office seekers
praised young Robert and predicted that
he he had a great future ahead of him
although he was often critical of
organized religion hunter was a
committed Christian and took the
teachings of his faith seriously as he
noted in his memoirs the problem which
most deeply troubled me I found in the
Gospel of st. John which states for he
that loveth not his brother whom he has
seen how can he love God whom he has not
seen he goes on to describe the
soul-searching process that he
experienced as he approached adulthood I
found it difficult to harmonize in my
mind my own acts and indeed the
practices of the clergy were the
teachings of Jesus how could I call
myself a Christian unless I really loved
others as myself as myself and shared
with those in need everything I
possessed this self-examination
eventually resulted in an abrupt and
dramatic transformation from contented
happy-go-lucky unreflective youth into a
serious young man totally committed to a
life of service to the poor a crucial
event at that time that seems to have
set him on the road to a Korean social
work and social reform was the
especially serious economic panic and
they called deep recessions and recent
depressions and those days panics that
struck the entire country in 1893
factories and businesses of all kinds
flows or dramatically reduced their
operations throwing millions of people
out of work
Chicago for example had just celebrated
its emergence as a major player in the
international marketplace by hosting a
World's Fair in April May
of 1893 to showcase its new economic
muscle
however as Charles finding a chronicler
of the city's history observed that that
sunny spring of self-congratulation was
followed by the worst winter of poverty
homelessness and starvation in the
city's history the black winter of 1893
94 when thousands froze on the streets
and fought for sleeping space in the
corridors of City Hall Terre Haute
although a small town and a little far
away from Chicago was not immune from
these economic dislocations falling
prices caused the bankruptcy of many
previously prosperous farmers and local
businesses that depended on their trade
even those employers who survived
including hunters father were forced to
lay off large numbers of their workers
causing great hardship local charitable
organizations were overwhelmed with
requests for assistance from hungry
families Robert aged 19 at the time
volunteered to visit the homes of
unemployed workers and distributed food
to the needy what he witnesses in the
homes he visited shocked him he
recognition for one one who thought he
knew well his small town to discover the
noisome unsanitary conditions and
pitiable pitiful destitution of the
starving families who lived in the
filthy streets and alleys along the
river and beyond the railroad yards this
experience generated in him the Pharaon
resolved to undertake a lifelong quest
to relieve the sufferings of the poor
although hunters father had served as a
model of charity and personal generosity
firm Robert always standing ready to
respond to individuals in need and
support organized philanthropic causes
he was both astonished and alarmed when
his son announced his plan to devote his
life to working with the poor there was
no such profession at that time generous
people of means donated time and money
to relief of the needy but the work did
not connect on stitute a career hunter
was expected to mentor the family
business or become a lawyer and he
briefly tested his talents and interest
in those areas however he remained
resolute and his plan and his encounters
with two prominent figures in the
emerging fields of scientific charity
and political economy convinced him that
he was on the right track these were dr.
Philip ears and Professor John R Collins
when Hunter first met him
Ayers was secretary of the Cincinnati
Bureau of charities and he invited
Robert to visit the organization
observed the work being done there and
discussed hunters interest in
undertaking charity work on a full-time
basis hunter was appalled by the awful
social conditions and desperate need
that he observed in the slums of
Cincinnati and wanted instantly to
plunge into relief work
however ears convinced him that he was
not yet adequately prepared for such
work and encouraged him to enter Indiana
University there he should study
sociology economics and related subjects
with Professor Cummins and experience
that he would surely find interesting
and would also test his commitment to a
career in social work hunter follow
dears advice pursued a course of studies
under calm
and Verne confirmed his career goals and
diligently prepared himself for
employment as a social worker
immediately upon graduation from Indiana
University in 1896 hunter went to work
for years who was then organizing
secretary of the charity organization
Society in Chicago the conditions under
which ACOG owes tourists residents had
to survive in the best of times were
appalling but Hunter arrived in the
midst of yet another serious and
prolonged economic downturn and was
shocked at the sheer mac n numbers and
dire need of the unemployed workers and
the families who needed assistance he
was given responsibility for running a
relief office near the stockyards an
especially poor area of the city as he
noted later I spent most of my time
visiting the families who applied for
aid and mentally spiritually and
emotionally I was continually affected
by the conditions at that confronted me
while engaged in this relief work in
Chicago
Hunter initially stayed at the
Northwestern settlement house and later
at how house the famous settlement
founded by Nevada Nobel laureate Jane
Addams he was greatly influenced by
Adams and after remember and other
remarkable leaders of the settlement
movement at that time as was the case
with countless other young
college-educated settlement workers he
was transformed from someone who simply
sought to minister to the poor a
do-gooder in other words with a into a
passionate champion of social reform as
he recalled one day the rather
terrifying thought came into my mind
that we were working
noxious swamp where almost everyone was
being laid low by malaria racking his
brain to remember how many families he
had helped by his individual relief
efforts he was forced to conclude that
there had been precious few as he put it
it was like swatting mosquitoes in
malarial swamp and he went on to
conclude there were so few that I became
melancholy over the prospect of spending
the rest of my life in such fruitless
endeavors my efforts I thought must be
directed to some other end and the real
work of my life should be that of a
social engineer intent upon draining and
clearing the swamps well in Chicago
hunter organized the nation's first
municipal shelter for homeless people
and under the tutelage of Adams wrote a
groundbreaking book on slum housing
called tenement conditions in Chicago
published in 1901 as a result of the
reputation that he began to acquire as
an energetic and effective social
reformer he was recruited to be head
resident that is the director of the
University settling in New York City
his skills were immediately put to the
test in New York when he was appointed
head of the campaign committee whose
goal was to outlaw the employment of
children and mines factories and
sweatshops under his tireless leadership
New York passed the nation's first
effective child labor laws which became
models of the rest of the country
wellhow House was America's best-known
settlement house the university
settlement was older and more
prestigious having Roosevelt's and
Rockefellers among its patrons and
active participants it was here that
Robert met his future bride Caroline
despite good
despite the press's reaction to the
marriage when it was announced which
took place in 1903 he actually Adam the
match was actually approved by
Caroline's family and seems to have been
actively actively encouraged by
Caroline's mother who included the young
couple in a small group that she took
for a trip to the Grand Canyon and
private railroad car the newlyweds had
planned to spend their honeymoon in
England where Roberts had friends from a
previous visit
in 1899 however it turned into quite
remarkable an unconventional honeymoon
sometimes accompanied by car line and
sometimes alone hunter spent much of
this time in England meeting with
socialists and other leftist thinkers
and politicians he also visited
organisations that attempted to put
social its principles into practice the
proximity to England of other European
countries that promised to provide
similar or perhaps even more instructive
examples of social reform thinking and
action were too tempting for Robert to
pass up therefore their itinerary was
extended to include among other things a
visit to Leo toys Tolstoy at his country
estate in Russia visits to Gore Jewish
communities and the pale of settlement
between Russia and Poland and visits to
locations where they could see Germany's
comprehensive social welfare system in
action if you look at this picture
Caroline looks a little less sparkling
than she did
the pre-wedding photographs and maybe
that's because she actually was sick not
surprisingly got sick during this
traipse across Europe and they had to
spend three weeks for her to rest in
Warsaw before continuing their travels
this photograph was taken in Berlin
actually but they rested up in Warsaw
Chris Robert took the opportunity in
Warsaw to hunt down Polish partisans who
were promoting independence from Russia
were presently ruled that word at that
time rule Poland some of those folks
that he met during that time leader
became presidents of the Polish Republic
during the time that I became
independent in the early part of the
century at any rate it was an
interesting honeymoon trip upon the
return to New York Roberts book poverty
was published and it caused a sensation
opening Americans eyes for the first
time to the existence of widespread
poverty in the midst of unprecedented
wealth he estimated that at least 10
million and maybe as many as 20 million
people did not have a sufficient food
clothing or shelter to maintain a
minimal level of health and productivity
even more significantly he presented
convincing evidence that the great
majority of the poor were poor through
no fault of their own that most poverty
was socially caused and preventable by
appropriate government action this was
revolutionary thinking of the time and
made hunter a national authority on
social problems
HUL said poverty should be read by every
wealthy American and a New York Times
reviewer said it will have a million
readers
Hunter's advice was sought by the
nation's political and civic leaders
including President Theodore Roosevelt
who invited him to the house the White
House for consultation
it also propelled him into the ranks of
the social and cultural elite of the day
resulting in close friendships with Mark
Twain Jack London John Dewey Upton
Sinclair and others of like mind the
conclusions that flowed from poverty
that are that is the need for safe
workplaces sanitary housing workers
compensation widows pensions
unemployment insurance and a ban on
child labor fell far short of calling
for America's strengths for
transformation into a socialist society
in fact many of these social reforms
that hunter advocated soon became
central to the platforms of the newly
formed progressive party that Theodore
Roosevelt led as well as the progressive
wings of the Republican and Democratic
parties many of these reforms were
adopted actually adopted by individual
states and localities and served as
models for the national programs that
were later enacted under Franklin
Roosevelt's New Deal nevertheless Hunter
almost immediately joined the Socialist
Party because he along with an
astonishing cross-section of Americans
thought that it offered the best hope of
achieving the type of society they
believed this was a period the first two
decades of the 20th century the only
period in American history when
socialism was viewed as an acceptable
if not entirely respectable alternative
to the major political parties which had
become to be seen by hunter and others
as being a totally controlled
by big money they buy the melons the
Morgans the Rockefellers and the carnies
and at that time the people that Teddy
Roosevelt called
the malefactors of great wealth so they
joining the Socialist Party at that
particular time was not that unusual for
people even people of means its
membership included not only trade
unionists and intellectuals but also
religious leaders committed to the
social gospel a fair sprinkling of the
middle class and even a few millionaires
like hunter as he was by that time and
his brother-in-law Graham felt Stokes
could we take a look at that family
photograph of the Phelps Stokes family
this is the family that Robert hunter
married into sitting in the middle is
Anson Phelps Stokes one of the richest
men in America but also sitting in that
family photo or a number of socialists
Roberts not they're probably working to
finish up in poverty but sitting down
and the right-hand corner is Caroline a
member of the Socialist Party with
Robert jr. in her on her lap and behind
them second from the right is Caroline's
brother Graham Phelps Stokes also a
millionaire also a leader of the
Socialist Party of America next to
maryam is his wife Rose Pastore Stokes
Rose was an immigrant from Russia Jewish
immigrant from Russia who worked for
many years as a cigar factory worker in
Cleveland before moving to New York to
be a writer for the
New York Jewish Daily News and while
covering a story for the newspaper she
interviewed Graham Phelps Stokes they
were smitten with each other and got
married so here we have a number of
socialists she was a socialist before
she married Graham but here we have a
number of socialists in a very prominent
very wealthy American family at the
beginning of the last century hunter
rose quickly to a position of leadership
in the party being twice elected to the
National Executive Committee he also ran
as a socialist for the New York State
Assembly in 1907 and for believe it or
not governor of Connecticut in 1910
these were unsuccessful campaign
campaigns but others socialist
candidates were as successful in
elective office including mayor's quite
a number of state legislators and even a
couple of UST's congressmen while he was
active in the Socialist Party he
travelled to Europe as a delegate to
socialist congresses and while studying
the revolutionary movements that were
going on at that time and that brought
him in contact with such folks as Lenin
Trotsky Tolstoy as I'm noted and Maxim
Gorky Benito Mussolini
when Melissa Mussolini was an official
of the Italian Socialist Party George
Bernard Shaw and HTU else his accounts
of these encounters and his writings
make fascinating reading his friendships
and conflicts with such American
socialist leaders as the UD Eugene Debs
the
perennial much-beloved and perennial
socialist candidate for president Samuel
Gompers the longtime leader of the
American Federation of Labor Rose pastor
Stokes when we've seen here his
sister-in-law and Emma Goldman the
anarchist socialist and big bill Haywood
word leader of the International Workers
of the world the Wobblies as they were
called are also intriguing hunter
claimed that among his most important
contributions to the Socialist Party was
to persuade acquired and exhausted Deb's
to run for president for a third time in
1908 this blocked the threatened
candidacy of Hayward to lead the
socialist ticket a situation that in
view and the view of Hunter and hay
other party moderates would have been a
disaster for the socialist cause on
account of he words militancy struggles
between those like hunter and Deb's who
favored gradual societal change through
democratic processes and those like
Haywood who were willing to use any
means necessary including violence to
bring about the desired revolution began
to undermine hunters health and and
actually his faith in the socialist
cause when World War one came the
Socialist Party of America was virtually
destroyed by the conflicts over
America's entry into the war and the Red
Scare that followed Deb's and rose
pasture storks Stokes and many others
receive prison sentences for their
opposition to the war and just
disillusioned Robert hunter resigned
from the party and moved to California
for health health reasons he continued
to be to study the ways in which
societies might organize
selves to achieve fairness and
prosperity for all the citizens as
book-y we fail as Christians published
in 1919 reflected on his an ongoing
quest to find a way to live one's life
and full accord with one's religious
beliefs the impulses that land him from
an early age to live in accordance with
his these religious principles continued
to innovate Enemy 10 in this book he
wondered how Christians in a society of
their own making can observe without
pain or protest poverty slums child
labor low wages long hours and all the
known evils of our industrial life
during the nineteen twenties once he had
moved to California hunter pursued a
passion that was somewhat at odds with
the with his championship of the world's
poor and oppressed at a time when golf
was exclusively a pastime those are very
wealthy he wrote a pioneering book on
golf court design called the Linx
originally published in 1926 it was
destined to become a classic when new
editions still finding their way into
print today the last one I found was
print published in 1999 in addition to
this remarkable and enduring
contribution to the theory of golf
course design he created along with his
partner Dolls
dr. Alistair McKenzie some of the best
golf courses in California most notably
the Cypress Point Club at Pebble Beach
which is consistently ranked among the
best and most beautiful golf courses in
the world I'm going to stop at this
point I can go on further and we'll fill
in more details of the later parts of
Hunter's life if people are interested
but I'd like to pause and give folks an
opportunity to
comment on what I've said so far or or
ask questions there may be a reluctance
to break the ice with questions and I
can go on a little bit toward the end of
his life while still committed to
speaking out for for the disadvantaged
and the dispossessed he became a bit
more conservative
he continued to study revolutionary
movements in Europe primarily and was
utterly dismayed by the unintended
consequences of those movements
particularly the dictatorships of the
right and the left that emerged in in
Europe the dictatorship of the left in
the case of vast Allanon in Russia and
in reaction the dictatorships of
Mussolini and Hitler and Germany in
reaction to they to the revolutionary
movements and therefore he concluded
that revolutions were dangerous because
you couldn't predict the outcome and he
wrote a very important book just to year
and that was published just two years
before he died
published in 1940 called revolution and
any of he analyzed those processes in
Europe and came to the conclusion that
that capitalism for all of its faults
and it had many many faults and he laid
them out in great detail in in
revolution but despite those faults it
probably was the best system for
ensuring people's Liberty and and
ultimately for their prosperity
simultaneously with the publication of
revolution he actively campaigned for
will rank Wendell Willkie which summer
give me remember was the Republican
opponent to Franklin Roosevelt in in
1940 Roosevelt was running for an
unprecedented third term as as past
president and lots of folks including
Hunter were worried that you know he was
going to be President for life maybe he
was going to be following in the style
the the steps of the dictators and
Europe meant and our present minds that
sounds a bit exaggerated an alarmist but
there were people who were genuinely
concerned about that and so hunter read
supported Wendell Willkie in his
unsuccessful effort to rest up the third
term of their of reservoir
questions/comments
put everybody to sleep
yes sir there is a microphone there okay
thank you
excellent question how did hunter relate
to religious leaders of the time and he
actually was very continued to be you
know a Christian a lot of people think
this is very strange how a person who's
a devoted Christian could at some point
ally himself with socialists many of
whom were you who believed that religion
was the opiate of the masses you know
not Sarah was put by some of the more
radical socialists of the time so there
is a question know her how did he he
maintained his religious belief how did
it play out in his work on behalf of the
poor and how did it relate to her there
are other religious leaders of the time
well he was very close to many of the
leaders of what was called the social
group and gospel movement that I
mentioned and these were people of
religion who believed very strongly that
the country the US was headed in the
wrong direction that that what was being
played out
on the national scene was the pursuit of
partner self-interest the pursuit of
greed the disregard for the poor among
us and that something needed to be done
about now lots of people involved in the
religious community were very active in
providing relief to the poor you know
making sure that people got food if they
were hungry provided shelter if they
could possibly provide it and clothing
and everything else that they were
capable of doing but the people in the
social gospel movement thought that it
was necessary to go beyond simply
offering handouts to the needy they saw
that that was insufficient and didn't
meet people's needs beyond the immediate
emergency what was needy was a reform of
the system so that it would be more fair
and would be in fact more in accord with
the teachings of all of the major
religions most of the folks active at
that time were you know you know people
of the Christian faith in the u.s. both
Protestants and Catholics but also there
was a significant movement in the Jewish
community to respond to these kinds of
means for example I mentioned the the a
settlement movement there were many
Jewish settlements that were active in
the major cities of the of the I was a
East and Northeast and Midwest who are
attempting to address these kind of
things so Hunter was a you know an ally
he didn't belong formally to the social
gospel movement but he was an ally
those religious leaders who said it
isn't enough to simply give you no
charity to needy people we need to
change the system in order that it is
more fair and equitable and we don't
have people living in poverty because
there is sufficient well-being generated
by this booming new American economy
Edward Allen Brawley is a professor
emeritus of Social Work at Arizona State
University he's written numerous
articles and books on social policy
including Social Care at the front line
and Human Services and the media for
more information visit asu.edu